okay just act natural i'm trying to but
i forgot how to walk
oh and now i forget i think we're doing
it right
you're doing it there you are they know
about you
what if they saw your picture they know
what you look like we have to go now
okay where do we go
i don't know oh my god oh my god oh my
god okay listen to me very carefully
i'll get you out of there
ah repeat you've got agents coming your
way from men's wear and electronics make
a left at aisle nine and we'll lose them
in grocery
thank you dina go now you're gonna find
yourself in a situation
where you're dating a girl and you
realize she's like an immigrant or
whatever
and you got to choose between your love
and your country
hasn't come up oh you choose love though
yeah i can tell i know your type
okay keep walking come on all right when
you hit the end of the aisle you're
gonna need to head due
west where left or right tina left new
restaurants diagonally through the store
from camping to customer service how do
you not know that
left
hey oh oh oh there's someone run come on
come on come on come on come on
they're heading north through housewares
get out of here
so everyone knows now everyone knows
do you want to get married
okay
okay you guys need to keep going
straight through the beauty and we're
gonna try to make it all the way to the
end of the dark section all right let's
go
did you know that the capital of panama
is panama i can rap the entire central
american countries i did it once for a
talent competition
mexico de fe mexico guatemala guatemala
stop reverse course turn around okay uh
new plan uh hide them
no no wait turn around turn around go
back go back the other way
uh you could lose some housewares i
think just book it okay book it to the
end this one go down here
stop stop no wait stop there's like 20
guys coming that way
stop stop no there's another one there's
no hold on hold on dude just tell us
where to go
okay hang on just wait wait i i don't
i don't know they're everywhere
what i'm sorry no
um okay there's a vent up there we can
climb up on the thing and we'll go
create a diversion and take off our tops
while you go run yeah let's do that okay
stop stop guys it's okay
it's over
[Music]
what do we do now i mean we have to
fight this
how
[Music]
no idea
want to start a union
[Music]
you